[Music]
let's go to
k in tulsa oklahoma what's up k
no not much harry
not much either here just
bumming around what's up how can i help
um so
basically
um in june 2020 uh i attempted
you know i i was in the hospital due to
her attempt to suicide and it's been two
years and
basically i just
i need some tools kind of to stay
motivated and
to not hate myself whenever like dark
thoughts come back up
um
and
you know i don't
it's a very it's just so weird like i
you know i love life but i love my
family but it's so easy
for me to get knocked down if there's
just any amount of you know
me feeling anything bad you know like
anybody hurting my feelings
um which are super sensitive like it's
like of course i became a live wire
after the incident
um
and
the person you know
there was a lot of things that kind of
made that happen in june
but the main thing was um
my daughter's dad and he moved back
into the house because he was working
for halliburton when the oil field kind
of laid people off he
i told him you know you can come back
and stay until you get a place
and inside i was you know
i guess i was hoping for like my
daughter to have the life that she
hadn't had with her parents really and
um
it's almost like he moved in to just
like totally shoot me down
and
um yeah
it yeah there was just a lot of
manipulation
and
so whenever i think back on those days
leading up to it and
you know being in the hospital for a
week and then having to go somewhere
else to stay for a week there's just so
much anger that blows up like it was
such an injustice
because nobody knows like
you know what he did or
nobody knows like the full story
and um
why does it why does it matter that
somebody else
knows um
i don't know
so as i have like i have
as i'm hearing you talk the question
that keeps coming to my mind is
somebody somewhere maybe multiple people
like who told you
that your feelings don't matter
or who told you that your space is
burdensome that just you being around is
is annoying who told you that that your
parents myself
no but that but that came from somewhere
um
did you get that from your family you
get that from cousins or
a little bit my family mostly my mom's
side and
my grandmother like they all
really really struggle with depression
um
and so
i don't know this kind of sounds weird
but i've always tried to be like the
strong one you know and like keep
everything good and happy and
then that happened and you know my mom
she already struggled with depression
and she just
it made it so much worse and hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
you didn't make it so much worse
you didn't
you don't have that kind of power you
don't have that kind of influence
your mom's body is your mom's body and
it contains a cocktail of
genetics and depression is genetic
and she it contains a cocktail of
whether she's gone to see a professional
and she's on medication she's taking
care of herself in therapy and she's
moving her body and exercising and all
the things
life happens
and we all have a series of genetics who
are born with then we have a series of
choices that we make every single day
and when someone's struggling with heavy
depression and you you
okay you deal in the black hole right
you know what i'm talking about
it's like being at the beach and all of
a sudden that water you can't touch all
of a sudden right
yeah yeah
and most people are like i'm depressed
okay you know what that's actually like
and what you can't do when you find
yourself at the beach you can't
just suddenly get taller right you can't
just your legs can't just shoot up and
suddenly you can touch the bottom and
you can't just suddenly be a stronger
swimmer right that takes years of
practice on the backhand
and you can't suddenly just have a body
like michael phelps that's genetic he
just got that body that he was born a
human fish right
you know
here's what you can do
you can say help
and people will come
and somebody along the way told you
you're not worthy of saying the words
help please
and listen to me i'm sorry that nobody
told you that because you're worth that
okay
there's a difference between guilt and
shame i don't think you're experiencing
guilt
guilt is i did something that i regret
or that violates my core value and so
let's say you grew up around a lot of
people with depression who are always
attempting suicide and you said i'll
never do that
and then one night you found yourself in
a dark hole and it happened
and you feel quote unquote guilty
imagine yourself picking up a brick and
you're holding that thing that's guilt
yeah when you unzip your backpack and
put that brick back there and carry it
that's shame
yeah it's the difference between
i
did something and i am something
and you have
given yourself a label
of somebody who does these kind of
things and i don't buy it for a second
i think you're about strength and i
think you're about bravery and i think
you were hurting so bad and you had a
gift you had to step back from the brink
that's what i think
and then whenever i woke up there was
such like a
feeling of wow you know
i try to explain it to like you know my
boyfriend and it just doesn't come out
well no it's an out of body experience
right
it's yeah i just you know it's like not
real does it feel like yeah it's like
looking it's like watching a movie with
like a like a blanket in front of it
it's like you can kind of see it but it
just feels weird right
and that yes there's never such there
was a feeling whenever i woke up that
was just like so beautiful like nobody
can touch me like like i have me and i
will always have me yeah and
that you know
money i was so worried about money like
things don't those things just don't
matter and it's been two years and i try
to like find that feeling again yes so
getting more different yeah yeah you're
chasing ghosts there
that feeling isn't external that feeling
comes from inside you
okay
if you go chasing a feeling that's
heroin right that's chasing this that's
just chasing the ghost man
like yo like you
that's not where you're gonna find that
yeah you're gonna find it from the
inside out so listen to me
one of the cornerstones of depression is
i hurt
and my hurt is my fault and it will
always be this way
yeah
i'm telling you
if you'll put the work in it will not be
yeah and god nobody's told you this
you're worth the work okay
okay thank you
do you believe that
yeah yeah
i mean
so listen um i think who you are is
beautiful
who you are strong
and who you are is brave and here's how
i can say that because 99 of people have
no idea the
octopus tentacles that have you run the
ankles sometimes wanting to pull you
into water right
and you just look like a sweet old mama
going to the grocery store to get some
milk and bread and god these prices are
so expensive and nobody knows how hard
that next step after the next step after
the next step is right
yeah
so
here's what bravery looks like
are you seeing somebody
yeah
yeah
i think it's been like a year and a half
now um
are you medicaid are you on medication
um we'll be cheering okay
it may be time to go get those checked
out
yeah okay i uh i need i need to find an
actual counselor that's one thing that
he pushes me towards i had one for two
years during the accident
and
she
she didn't ask anything like you know
that she should have like about my
childhood like where things kind of
started
and she um
basically anytime i brought up
that things were still sticking to me
and i couldn't handle you know deal with
it properly
she would just tell me get over it it's
a big day
thanks man like no way i hadn't thought
of that
right okay just get over it
so listen if you took your car
to get an oil change and they didn't put
the plug back in all the oil drained all
over the ground and they were um they
went to squeegee your window and the the
pad was off and it just raked like
across your windows and cut into your
window
and then the guy just spit on the
windshield
okay right and then you drove off
listen listen would you never get your
oil changed again no of course you would
no you'd have to
you just wouldn't get it done there
yeah okay yeah so you have to
go talk to a counselor you need to go
back to your psychiatrist or your pcp
and get your meds adjusted and yeah
you've got to go talk to a counselor
please do you promise me i will i
promise no i will that was my plan still
one one thing i do want to ask you yep
um
i had serotonin syndrome and it took
like apparently it took the doctors a
while to figure out that i had that
because it's so rare
serotonin syndrome
yeah children's syndrome i've never even
heard of that is that a serotonin
deficiency i know right
it's it's no it's where you have too
much serotonin in your body and um
yeah
they had to induce me into a coma
because my i could my whole body was
jerking like it
you know serotonin has a lot to do with
your nerves so if it's overloaded like
okay
yeah so um anyway
um my doctor he at first put me on ssris
and that just floods the thing even more
yeah i know um and i waited because i
had i was on one thing and i was having
seizures afterwards for like six months
until i guess my system leveled out
because they weren't able to like pump
my pump my stomach or anything i already
been too long
but um
so the ssris whenever i take them now
that's why i'm on my b trip
is i it's like it's like i feel it too
much you know like i'm too sensitive to
anything serotonin okay so so there's
some
there's some incredible therapeutic
techniques
for
handling
feelings
there's rebt there is um
uh i think it's cbt there's several
different things that usually use with
folks who struggle with borderline
personality disorder where the feelings
feel and i'm not saying that's what you
have i'm just i'm that's it was designed
for that
but
that may be a place to start and what it
does is it it
teaches you here's what my feelings are
doing to my body
and let me weave through that jungle and
find reality
or even though my reality feels this
strong
here's how the rest of the world is
feeling that same thing yeah and you
learn to it's almost like running on
prosthetics right you're taking a step
and your body feels that you aren't all
the way on the ground but your body's
still held up right okay you learn
to adapt with to your feelings to a
less a non-non-feeling world basically
um
but listen all of that is
um
you getting with somebody that you trust
and the next time you were the counselor
i want you to take the lead when you get
there
okay
here's what that's like
stop carrying the shame around i will
join your other therapist in that okay
yeah you are not a failure
you're not a lunatic and you're not a
loser do you believe me yeah
yeah no i do i want you to clip that and
make it your ringtone don't make it your
ringtone that'd be super weird
okay but listen you're not
did you try to take your life yes you
did that happened i'm gonna own that it
happened yeah yeah um there was a
cocktail of things that happened by the
way i don't think it was just that one
event i think there was an entire season
right and get an entire picture that
wasn't going to come true so yeah
i'm going to create a new identity that
is i'm somebody who's going to live
yeah and not just have breath
i'm gonna have be somebody who has joy
and laughter
and rambunctious intimacy with my spouse
and i'm gonna be
i'm going to live and so then i'm gonna
have to go do the things
that help me to live and if you have a
generational
um
uh
generational depression that goes that
you can look back lineage then you're
probably gonna need medication and
that's fantastic
what an age that we live in when
somebody in your situation can get help
okay
you're gonna have to take it you're
gonna have to go you're gonna have to go
sit down with a counselor and look at
the counselor and say hey i'm gonna
start the meeting off i've got this much
abuse and trauma in my childhood
um
i've had been impatient because i tried
to take my life i've how many kids you
have
this one i've got one beautiful little
kid i've got a knuckleheaded boyfriend
i'm trying to figure out
and
i need help with all of it but i
especially need help with the depression
and the suicidal ideation i need you to
be that clear
you hedge your bets if you go back and
listen to this when you told me about
what happened
you told me from a position of shame
and i want you to tell me begin to tell
the story from a position of ownership
this happened
and look at me now
yeah okay that
that feeling you said that you felt when
you open your eyes
it's pretty common there's some really
remarkable research that people who
um try to take their life
um off the golden gate bridge i think it
is
people who lived
90 something percent of them went on to
live their life
yeah what that tells me is they didn't
really want to go down that hole when
they jumped no no that would be up
same with you yeah i am
yeah i uh i put in an email you know
that's the one thing i really struggle
with is whenever i woke up i just i
couldn't believe i had done that and
then i kind of remembered what had
happened and
i remember
that night when it was happening
it was like i was in the back of my head
yelling at myself don't do that that's
right but
i was in so much pain like i really just
wanted to wait i wanted to stop that's
right that's right but most of the
people i've met with over the years
um
in a similar situation have said those
exact words i didn't want to die i just
wanted this hurt to stop
and you've heard the colloquial is like
a pinterest quote but that's like a
permanent solution to a temporary pain
right literally um and so here listen
somebody told you
that that voice didn't count
and i'm telling you it does
that voice in the back saying don't do
it don't let this guy move in here don't
take one more pill don't pull that
trigger
that voice matters because that's your
voice
fair
hope
so
i'll say it one more time
who you are is beautiful
and who you are is strong
and who you are is brave even when you
don't feel like it
and the next bravest thing you can do
is make that phone call to a counselor
and say today's a day
let them know what happened with your
last counselor
all right if i would've got my oil
changed i would tell them hey last time
i would got my oil changed dude spit it
and scratch my car up please don't do
that
i would do the same thing right
yo yes okay
my life is better
because you're still here
my kids life is better because you're
still here your kids life is better
because you're still here your
community's life is better because we're
still here and i want you to never ever
forget you are not a burden
the people in your life their life is
better because you're in it
and you're worth being well
thank you so much for sharing your story
you're brave brave young woman
can't wait to see those pictures of that
wedding we'll see you soon